[Music]
foreign
T and I'm here to share with you three
reasons why I hope you will join me at
the Big Data with arrow and R workshop
at positconf this coming September
my first reason
doing data analysis on bigger and bigger
data is becoming commonplace for many
data professionals and I think that it
is fair to say that our data is only
going to get bigger
in the Big Data with arrow and R
Workshop you will learn how to Wrangle
your very large data
even when that data is so large it won't
fit on the memory of your computer
this will feel like a superpower
my second reason
you will learn to Wrangle your too large
for memory data on your computer without
having to learn a new programming
language or even new R syntax
you'll be introduced to Apache Arrow
which is a tool kit designed for
efficient in-memory data analysis on our
large data
and the arrow for our package is built
with a d-plier back end so you'll be
wrangling this large data on your laptop
with familiar to you D plier and base R
syntax syntax
my third reason along the way while we
are learning these things you will pick
up many data engineering tips and tricks
that will definitely save you time and
friction when you're building out your
data workflows using R and especially
when you're building those data
workflows with growing or already very
large data sets
and I'm going to throw in a bonus reason
for joining me at the Big Data with
arrow in our workshop and that is I'll
be co-instructing with Nick crane
this is Nick
not only is Nick an art educator Nick is
currently one of the core developers and
maintainers of the aero4r package so we
will have an expert in the room with us
so if you are ready to tackle those two
big data sets in your life with arrow
using R please join Nick and I at the
posit comp
2023 in Chicago
[Music]